So tonight, I want to focus less on a checklist of proposals...
...and focus more on the values at stake in the choices before us.
It begins with our economy.
We've seen the fastest economic growth in over a decade, our deficits cut by two-thirds,...
...a stock market that has doubled...
...and health care inflation at its lowest rate in fifty years.
So the verdict is clear.
Middle-class economics works.
Expanding opportunity works.
And these policies will continue to work, as long as politics don't get in the way.
So what does middle-class economics require in our time?
First, middle-class economics means helping working families feel more secure...
...in a world of constant change.
That means helping folks afford childcare, college, health care, a home, retirement.
Second, to make sure folks keep earning higher wages down the road,...
...we have to do more to help Americans upgrade their skills.
Finally, as we better train our workers,...
...we need the new economy to keep churning out high wage jobs for our workers to fill.
I believe in a smarter kind of American leadership.
We lead best when we combine military power with strong diplomacy.
First, we stand united with people around the world who've been targeted by terrorists...
...from a school in Pakistan to the streets of Paris.
Second, we're demonstrating the power of American strength and diplomacy.
We're upholding the principle that bigger nations can't bully the small...
...by opposing Russian aggression and supporting Ukraine's democracy...
...and reassuring our NATO allies.